JENNY: Hi everyone.
Jenny Murphy here.
Welcome to another episode
of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
Today we're going to have an
open questions and answer
session, so now is your chance
to ask us anything and
everything about developing
on the Google+ Platform.
So about the REST APIs,
Hangout APIs, even our
dinosaur as well.
So before we get going, I'm
going to introduce the
people around me.
So starting with the people who
are joining me in person
at the Googleplex, we have--
CHIRAG: Chirag Shah, Developer
Programs Engineer on the
Google+ platform.
And--
SILVANO: And I am Silvano
Luciani, Developer Programs
Engineer [INAUDIBLE]
of the Google+ Platform.
JENNY: Yes, you flew in all
the way from London for us
today, right?
SILVANO: And I'm still
jet-lagged.
JENNY: Oh, and you're
still jet-lagged?
Well, thanks for getting up.
And joining us via the magic of
Hangouts, in no particular
order, specifically the order
from left to right in my
little filmstrip at the
bottom of the Hangout.
Starting with you, Allen.
ALLEN: Hi there, I'm
Allen Firstenberg.
I'm a Outside Developer that
does Hangout apps primarily.
JENNY: And, how about Chad?
CHAD: I'm Chad LaFarge.
I'm in Columbia, Missouri.
I developed Pro Studio.
We might touch on
that later on.
But I'm relatively new to
Hangout extension development.
JENNY: Great.
And Charles?
CHARLES: I'm Charles Jaimet, I'm
a developer in Canada, and
one of the co-developers of
Tabletop Forge, which is a
Hangout app for playing games.
JENNY: Great.
And Fraser?
FRASER: Hi, my name's
Fraser Cain.
I'm the publisher of Universe
Today, and we've been doing a
virtual star party on Google+
where we connect telescopes
into Hangouts.
JENNY: Gerwin?
GERWIN: Yeah, I am Gerwin
from Austria.
I'm most probably well-known
for the Comment Tracker
extension, and I recently did
Hangout Band Hangout app,
which is fun, I think.
JENNY: Very cool.
And last but not least, Jason.
JASON: Hi everybody, I'm Jason
Salas, and I am from Guam,
where it is about 4:50 in
the morning right now.
So I got up, and I'm very, very
happy to be with you fine
folks and everybody out there
streaming on the net.
I am a software developer and a
sportscaster, and a marketer
for a large TV station
out here.
And I do a lot of R&D,
specifically
with the Hangout API.
And I'm really excited to be
here and just talk about some
of the neat stuff that's going
on in our community.
JENNY: Great.
Thanks for the intros,
everyone.
So while we wait for the
questions to queue up, there
is some news that is pretty
exciting that we've been
following for a while.
The Tabletop Forge has launched
a Kickstarter and is
achieving great success
so far.
And I think someone here knows
something about that.
CHARLES: Well what do you
want to know about?
We put the Kickstarter up on
Saturday morning, and Joshuha
Owen and I, who put it up, along
with two others, Joseph
Schnurr and Andrew Chason,
who did our design.
It was our first Kickstarter,
so we were all very nervous
the night before.
And we hit our goal
in one day.
So we put up what we thought was
a fairly modest, hittable
goal at $5,000, which seems to
be the sort of standard amount
and enough to get us going.
And we hit that.
By Sunday morning, we had to
put up a stretch goal.
And then we had to put up a
second stretch goal, and we're
now $430, 20, $413-- my
math is bad today--
away from hitting that
goal, so we got
another one lined up.
JENNY: Oh, you have another
stretch goal lined
up after that one?
CHARLES: Yeah, Jonathan Roberts,
who does a lot of RPG
maps, is going to give
us a license to a
bunch of his maps.
So basically the Kickstarter,
the app, is a way to play
role-playing games online
in a Google Hangout.
So role-playing games like
Dungeons and Dragons is
probably the most well-known,
but then there are hundreds of
others that allow you to create
a fantasy or sci-fi or
historic setting, and for a
number of people who play
characters inside that setting
and then to explore the world.
And so it's a strategy,
tactical game.
It's also a collective
storytelling game, depends
entirely on how you play it
and which ruleset you use.
But normally it's played at a
table, and then you've got on
the tabletop in front of you,
sometimes a map, sometimes
some pictures, some visual
aids to play the game.
Sometimes people use little
miniatures to represent
themselves going
through rooms.
You roll dice, and we reproduced
that experience in
the Hangouts.
So it's just pretty cool.
Makes the game actually work so
you can see what somebody
else has rolled, as opposed to
somebody rolling their die
off-camera and saying
oh, I got a 12.
So that's been our experience,
and the Kickstarter's mostly
about trying to get--
right now it looks like
something designed by
programmers, which it is.
And what we want it to look like
is something designed by
designers with beautiful
artists' work in there.
Because that's what really makes
things pop, people are
very visual.
So we're getting indie
designers and indie
cartographers and game
developers to license their
works to us so that we can
incorporate them into the app.
That's basically
the gist of it.
JENNY: Very cool.
Yeah, I've always loved this
application because it's a
great example of something
really cool that you can do
with Hangout apps that are hard
to do on other platforms.
Hangout apps are a lot like
having a kitchen table in
front of you.
And applications that leverage
that kind of metaphor seem to
work really well.
And the best ones are where you
can start to do things in
the Hangout that are hard
to do in reality.
For example, in tabletop gaming,
it's hard to roll a
one or seven-sided die.
But having Hangout apps you
can do it, and it actually
seems to make the games
flow really well.
And people have called it
a great example of both
leveraging Hangout
apps in that way.
CHARLES: Thanks.
You know, it's funny, Fraser's
always in these hangouts when
I'm in them.
Fraser's the reason that I got
into building in Hangout apps
in the first place.
He and I were playing a game
called Ars Magica in his
living room, which I think you
can actually see behind him.
We used to go in there once a
week on Tuesdays and play this
game, Ars Magica.
And then slowly people drifted
away from the game.
They had obligations, some guy
got a girlfriend, the nerve,
and then moved to
another city.
And it just kind
of fell apart.
And we decided we'd take a look
at doing it in Hangouts,
and that's where I got
programming, and that's where
I met Josh.
And I don't even have
a physical game
anymore that I go to.
I keep nagging Fraser to start
up an Ars Magica game again,
but all my gaming now is online
through Hangouts and it
works really, really well.
And I've met some really cool
people, too, in the process,
which has been the added
benefit that I
didn't really expect.
I just thought I'll get
my game going, I'll
find a couple people.
But really, I've played with
some of the people whose
rulebooks I've read.
You get connected to these
really amazing people, and
then they play and you go oh,
wow, I didn't even know you
could play that way.
It's kind of like playing chess
in your basement for
your entire life, and then all
of a sudden you get online,
and you can play with
Garry Kasparov.
FRASER: Yeah, geography just
doesn't matter anymore.
Like Charles says, we live in
a small town, it's brutal to
try and get an actual gaming
group together, especially for
something that's really obscure,
like Ars Magica, that
we like to play.
But boy, there's a thread on
Google+ right now that has 30
people who love the game
and really want
to play it in Hangout.
So we could easily put together
a group from all
those people.
And instead of having to drag
people kicking and screaming
into a game system they don't
understand, you've got people
who are totally into
playing the game.
So it's just great.
Geography just doesn't
matter anymore.
JENNY: That's really cool.
I can't wait to see what other
cool, cute things along this
line people come up with
in the future.
SILVANO: Yeah, I think also a
great achievement of such an
application is that it's easy
for players to join because of
the game engine is simplified.
But you keep the role-playing
aspect because you are
role-playing your character in
the Hangout, and you can be a
wizard, the fighter, the
whatever it is and actually
role-play, which is great.
JENNY: Yeah, that
is very cool.
CHARLES: Have you guys
tried it out yet?
JENNY: I have tried it out
very little beyond our
experiences in these Hangouts,
unfortunately.
It's a little bit of a
busy time here for
those of us at Google.
We have a conference or
something coming up I hear.
CHARLES: So I hear.
JENNY: Yeah, but once that's
done, it's definitely my top
Hangout apps that I want to
start playing with more.
Cool, okey-doke.
So, thanks for filling
us in on what's new
with Tabletop Forge.
Before we go to questions
outside of the Hangout, how
about inside the Hangout?
Because questions are best
asked in person.
So, do any of you have questions
for us about your
recent developments on
the Google+ platform?
FRASER: Yeah, I got a question,
which is that I love
the Pro Studio app for the
Hangout, and I love the
Comment Tracker app, and I
love the Lower Third one.
And yet I can't run all three
at the same time, so you've
made me choose.
And I've had to--
and are you ready?
My choice is the Comment
Tracker,
which is just amazing.
It completely changed my
life, I got to say.
Because when we run these
Hangouts, we'll have hundreds
of people watching.
The comments are showing up
over on Google+, they're
showing up on Twitter, they're
showing up on YouTube, all at
the same time.
And I was having to sort
of switch windows.
And every time I would switch a
window, the memory footprint
would change, and then
my stream would gimp.
So anyway, the Comment Tracker
is fantastic, and I've been
pitching lots of features
at Gerwin.
But I love the Pro Studio
features as well, but I can't
run them both at
the same time.
So, will it ever be possible
to run multiple
apps at the same time?
JENNY: Well, already today, you
can, as I'm sure you know,
but maybe not everybody knows,
you can run an extension and
an application at the same.
An extension being one of those
that sits in the side
and the application being
one that runs in
the rest of the Hangout.
And that gives you a little bit
of flexibility, but we're
definitely [? looking at ?] ways
that we can expand that.
The obvious challenges are that
when two Hangout apps use
the same features, they can
stomp on each other and cause
all sorts of headaches for the
developers trying to make
their apps compatible with other
simultaneously running
applications.
And there are some other
challenges we're facing, but
that's definitely something
we're looking into,
and Google is, too.
FRASER: Either that, or just get
inspired by these features
and build them right into
Hangouts itself.
Because a lot of them are
pretty fundamental.
JENNY: That would definitely
work, too.
Many of them, rolled into the
main products, that would free
up that extension or application
slot for one of
the other ones.
FRASER: Yeah, and I would
say all three pieces of
functionality are pretty core
for what you need to do.
So please.
JENNY: Great feedback.
CHAD: And that kind of brings us
to the moderation controls
that people have been
talking about,
asking about for awhile.
Part of the reason why Pro
Studio was developed was to
try and provide some of those
moderation controls.
Is Google looking at
incorporating greater control
for the host or the creator
of the Hangout?
JENNY: We're always looking
at adding more features.
It all depends on-- there's a
lot of stuff we want to add to
Hangouts, and we're adding new
capabilities every day.
In terms of what specifically
we're adding and when we're
adding them, I'm afraid this is
something we don't really
talk about.
Because things can change at any
time, and we don't want to
promise something and
not deliver it.
But moderation features are
definitely something that's on
our radar, and we've heard
a lot about that.
Not yet, hang in there.
CHIRAG: We've been listening
to the community, and we're
aware of a lot of
these features.
But we can't talk about
future releases.
JENNY: Yes, we cannot
see into the future.
Our vision into the
future is just as
limited as everyone else's.
SILVANO: But it will
be awesome.
JENNY: But it will be
awesome, that's the
one thing we promise.
It will be awesome
when it's around.
Whatever it is, it
will be awesome.
CHARLES: We had troubles over
the weekend with a Hangout On
Air where we were trying
to run the app.
And people weren't able
to see the app.
People weren't able to see the
app with the main screen.
What they were seeing was the
full video of the individual
people talking, but they
couldn't actually see the
board or the tokens moving.
JENNY: Oh, so they had the
application installed and
running, and it was
not rendering?
CHARLES: I had it installed
and running.
Everybody else in the
game did as well.
And then we ran an On
Air version of it.
And what the people watching saw
was just the main video.
So what I had to do was one of
the guys screen shared his
video window with me, and then
I stuck my video on that so
that everybody could see that.
But it meant that I couldn't
use the app.
I couldn't roll the
dice for myself.
I couldn't do anything.
The ideal work-around would have
been to get somebody else
who wasn't playing the game to
just log in just so that they
could run the On Air and lock
their screen on my window.
But everybody would only have
seen my window then.
CHAD: You want to be able to
have the broadcast user kind
of run the app or
render the app.
And Allen, we were talking this
past Friday night about
being able to do that.
CHARLES: Yeah, so somebody
basically has to be the
broadcast user, and then they
can't actually be involved in
the game in any way.
ALLEN: Yeah, part of the problem
is that there's a
separate hidden user in
a Hangout On Air.
And it's basically recording
and doing what's doing the
streaming of the video stream.
But it's only looking
at the video stream.
So for example, when your app
is running, you're not
actually modifying the
video stream itself.
You're just modifying the rest
of the screen that's available
for your app to run.
Kind of a work-around that you
could do is that you could
have that portion being dumped
on top of your video stream.
And that would replace your
face with what your
application is showing.
Or use the work-around that you
have, with another person
logging in and sharing it.
Or eventually, convince the
Google development team to
allow the streaming user to
also be running apps.
But there are problems with
the streaming user running
apps as well.
CHARLES: So I'm going
for option C there.
FRASER: Right, but I guess as
you develop your app, you'd
want some way that you can
control portions that get put
out into the video, that you can
almost, as you said, you
can control the video stream
that's being displayed to the
public and be able to inject
relevant stuff into that
stream at the right time.
So in the example of the
Tabletop Forge, if a person
rolls some dice, then
everybody's going to want to
see the results of
that die roll.
But it's going to probably look
different than the map or
whatever that the person
is seeing.
And so you're going to have
something custom that's going
to need to be displayed just
for the Hangouts On Air
CHARLES: Well except that with
the API, you can pretty much
create that.
That's what our app shows is
what we want everybody to see.
So we take the main video, and
we embed it inside the app.
And it's a movable window,
and you've got another
window for your dice.
And then behind everything
you've got the map.
I just want that whole area
that's my app area, I want
that to be the On Air
video stream.
So pretty please.
JENNY: So that's a pretty good
summary of a bad situation.
So right now, the way to share
a Hangout app On Air is to
screen share someone running
the application, which then
has all those problems
you mentioned.
You're only seeing one user's
view, and then also the user
cannot use the app the
same way as they
would be able to otherwise.
And there are some interesting
challenges we want to make
sure we get right.
For example, if you were
broadcasting a game of poker,
each one of the players is going
to only be able to see
their cards and not the cards
of the other people involved
in the poker game.
And we have the open question of
what is the headless unique
Hangout user stream look like.
Is it everyone's cards?
Is it no one's cards?
Is it something that's up to
the application developer?
And would the application
developer have to
support this feature?
And those are things that we
still have open questions that
we're working through, but this
is definitely something
we're aware of.
CHARLES: That seems sort of
privacy, a public space is
probably going to come up with
us, too, but we've had people
ask us if they can have separate
desktops that are
just their own, or tabletops
that are just their own, so
that you would have a shared
space that every
player could see.
But then some games involve
cards as well, and you'd want
to be able to hide
your own cards.
But if you could just flag divs
or elements in the video
that were private and public,
that would solve
our problems at least.
I imagine whatever worked for
poker would work for us.
JENNY: That's an interesting
solution.
Because right now, the way you
would handle different players
with different cards is your
instance of the Hangout app
has to be aware of which cards
are yours and display those
and hide everyone else's.
But since it's all in the web
browser, there's always that
potential of somebody peeking
through with the
[? x-factor ?] or something
like that.
Because a shared state,
it'll share it
across all of the users.
CHARLES: We're going to take
it one step further and let
the GM probably look at
everybody's tabletops.
Because some games, especially
for new users, you're going to
want the GM to be able to look
at the person's cards and give
some suggestions and say
oh, you want to use
this and this together.
So the ability to share your
tabletop as well as keep it
private, or just have one person
who's the superuser.
FRASER: It's almost like you
want to have somebody thinking
like a director, right?
Because you've already got
these constraints.
You've got the constraints
of the window.
You've got the constraints of
the app environment that's
inside the window, and then
that's what's being broadcast.
And so a director or a
cinematographer, or director
of photography, would say oh,
well here's how we would
display these dice
being rolled.
And it might look completely
different than what the people
within the app are going to
see, but something that's
better displayed
for the public.
You might want to see a really
nice 3-D rendered seven-sided
die rolling down the table,
which would look completely
different than what the users
inside the app would see.
They'd probably have something
a little more utilitarian.
But if you're going to have--
ALLEN: This is broadcast
quality.
You want it to look like
broadcast quality.
FRASER: Yeah, and so the app
developer is going to need
some way to be able to code in
the broadcast quality into the
app itself.
Poker I think is a fantastic
example.
It deals with every problem
all at the same time, the
privacy, the public issue, the
custom views for every person.
And then what does
the public see?
I don't know, how do they do
it on a live game of poker,
when you watch it on TV?
CHAD: I wonder if you could do
like the interface elements,
or the private things, like your
cards, and you just do an
animated overlay.
Keep refreshing the overlay
for the public board that
everyone should be
able to see.
Did that make sense?
An overlay will broadcast, and
your interface would be
personal to everyone who's
using the app.
ALLEN: Yeah, the problem with
that, though, is that your
overlay now becomes overwriting
the thumbnail at
the bottom.
That was my first or
second suggestion.
So I think it's workable as
a work-around, but I think
long-term, we would want a way
to run these apps under the
video user and control that app
from somewhere, somehow.
JENNY: Very cool.
Yeah, so this would definitely
have a lot of really cool
potential for broadcasting
applications.
CHARLES: Especially
for Kickstarters.
We ran one game, and it got some
attention, but because we
had such technical issues,
because it was the first On
Air one that I'd done.
I hit Fraser up for some advice,
but still, it was a
bit of a fiasco for the
first 15 minutes.
It would be really nice to be
able to showcase what it is
that you're trying to raise
money for in a nice easy way.
So for anybody who's trying to
do it, you get one person
who's not involved to
do the On Air part.
FRASER: Yeah.
I mean we've found with the
number of Hangouts--
I mean, I've probably done about
50 Hangouts On-Air now.
And I mean, maybe it looks
really natural, but there's a
ton of prep work that we go
through with every person to
make sure their audio, their
video, their method of getting
their telescope into the Hangout
is working properly
and looking the way that
we want it to look.
It's actually a lot of work to
get that all done right.
So yeah, I can see trying to
show a role-playing game live
would have been tough.
CHARLES: It was pretty
funny, actually.
Because you don't want to be
watching your YouTube stream
at the same time that you're
broadcasting that.
So it took a while for us
to realize that we were
broadcasting nonsense.
FRASER: And if anyone wants, if
you go to my profile page,
I've got a great big laundry
list of all of my tips and
tricks for Hangouts On Air.
I've got all of the lessons that
I've learned so far, so
it's just on my Google+ profile,
there's a link to it.
JENNY: Great, well, we'll
put that in the
share notes for sure.
CHIRAG: There's one question
from Tom Birmingham on the
questions list.
Do you have any suggestions on
how to port my Android app to
run in the Hangout?
And that's a really
good question.
So if you have a native Android
application, it's
probably written in Java.
You first need to rewrite that
to use HTML, CSS and
JavaScript.
So your list views and all of
your views will need to be
represented as proper
HTML DOM elements.
And now if your Android
application understands the
multiplayer components, you can
start to use shared state
offered by Hangouts.
So you first need to do some
groundwork, and porting it
over to run on the
web browser.
And once you've done that, most
of the hard work is done.
And then you can go on to using
the Hangout APIs that
shared states [INAUDIBLE].
JASON: Well, there's an
interesting idea.
That's very clever, because
that also introduces the
possibility of, say, like if
somebody develops an app, like
a game or something like that.
And say--
sorry to bring up the licensing
thing-- but like if
somebody's playing Monopoly,
you could have some players
playing on an Android device
and then some players also
playing in a Hangout.
And you could actually
bridge the two
platforms at the same time.
Not necessarily like one or
the other, but you could
possibly bring in Hangout people
playing with people
that are truly on
mobile devices.
JENNY: That would
be really cool.
It would require some of your
own systems to give you some
of that synchronization.
Because the shared state
for that [INAUDIBLE]
Hangout is only available in
the Hangout itself, the
Hangout that's running.
If you want to start to involve
other devices and
other sources, like a web
front end or a mobile
application, and have them
playing the same real-time
game, that is definitely
possible.
But it will then be the
responsibility of the
developer to figure out a way
to synchronize those states
between multiple platforms.
And that might be kind of
challenging, depending on
what's happening in the game.
And it will be really cool
to see if someone did
take a spin at that.
CHAD: Anything really
time-sensitive is going to be
more difficult.
But yeah, having a central
server be the proxy to
communicate between the
different platforms, as long
as a couple hundred milliseconds
isn't going to
make a difference,
it'd be cool.
JENNY: Yeah, the unfortunate
part is it requires them to
reimplement a lot of the
features that make Hangout
apps really cool.
And we'll probably have to come
up with interesting ways
to bridge that, like have one
designated user in a Hangout
be the one that synchronizes
with the server.
I'm sure that when someone
attempts this, they'll come up
with lots of really interesting
best practices and
recommendations.
CHIRAG: Let us know if you
get around to doing that.
JENNY: Yeah, if you start
to port your internet.
Another implementation starting
from the internet
that might be probably just as
much work, couldn't you run it
as an applet?
Because then at least
it's Java.
But then you're going to have
to reimplement all the
interface features in an applet,
and then you'd have an
applet, which is not
very 21st century.
And then you'll have to write
all the bridging code, so
don't do that.
JASON: Hello, 1998.
Well, I have a question if I
may, unless you guys are going
to [INAUDIBLE] something.
Well, just a real quick update
on my Hangout app in
development.
Mine is actually stymied
because--
I don't know, some of you guys
know that I was actually
working on an app to allow paid
Netflix subscribers to
actually be able to watch movies
and enjoy them within
the same Hangout app and
everything like that.
I'm kind of running into a
little bit of road blocks with
Netflix themselves, so if
anybody is watching this from
Netflix, please answer
my emails.
I just want to know if it is
possible, and the whole
bridging solution.
We're trying to use the
Silverlight player over the
Hangout paradigm and
doing some of the
authentication stuff.
I don't want wax political,
but that's
where I'm at with that.
But I would really love
to pull that off.
Even if Netflix is working on
that right now, I would just
love to know.
If they are, I will
happily stand by.
Because there are a lot of
people that would certainly
like to take advantage of that,
of paying members being
able to watch the same
movie securely,
privately and legally.
But the larger point I wanted
to bring up, and I know I've
posted about this, and
Jenny and I have
talked about this privately.
But I think the facility that
you guys at Google have
provided us with before Hangouts
start is really cool.
You get that standby screen, or
I think the default screen
is the "We'll be starting in a
few minutes" in many different
languages and everything,
which is really slick.
But I had my idea, and I was
wondering, obviously this is
beyond us as developers, but
would you be able to provide
the ability for us to run
pre-Hangout apps?
Basically using the phrase
out-of-band for lack of a
better term.
But seeing as how many Hangouts
On Air don't always
start on time--
people wait for other
contributors to jump in, or
the producer, they run
behind schedule.
But coming from the TV industry,
I've always thought
it was cool where we put up that
screen, it's like sorry,
we'll be back in a minute,
technical difficulties.
But we can extend that because
we're on the internet.
And say if I'm running a show
and I'm running a few minutes
late, I would actually be able
to hook into some sort of data
source to say here's a bunch
of stock quotes, here's the
ballgame score, here's what's
coming up on your TV cable
system, or here's my
Google+ stream and
everything like that.
So we'd be able to run some
sort of data-centric,
interactive application
and everything
before the Hangout starts.
And then when we actually truly
broadcast and go live,
then the regular stream
kicks in.
FRASER: We had a similar problem
with that as well when
we were doing the Venus
transit coverage.
So we were broadcasting
the entire
transit of Venus on Google+.
It was great.
It was 6 and 1/2 hours of
broadcast, which we ran into
your four-hour limit, which is
an interesting discovery.
But it was really hard to
promote it in advance because
the actual location of the
stream didn't exist until we
began the stream.
So there was no easy way to tell
people, by the way, we're
going to be doing this event at
this location in five days,
and that was the amount of
lead time we had to do.
So really, we had to tell people
that we're going to be
doing, something but to then
come and dig around on Google+
until they find it.
Now, we were able to create a
redirection from a couple of
websites to create a more
permanent URL, but the reality
was there was just no way.
And so I think it would be a
very similar way that if you
could somehow reserve a
location, a permanent
location, a permalink to your
event that before that event
begins, before you click
broadcast, then there's a
notification that it is coming
in the future and even perhaps
when it's going to
be happening.
And then when you start to
broadcast, the two are
connected together, and then
your broadcast takes over at
that location.
And I think that would also
probably solve part of the
problems that Jason's saying,
where if you could somehow be
even more clever and put more
information in advance, or run
video or whatever ahead of time,
you'd be able to see
what's going to be coming
at that location.
CHARLES: Yeah, so I think those
two issues, I think
they're both really valid.
If you wanted to run something
before your video started and
not just a blank screen, you
could screen share a
PowerPoint presentation or a
website that cycles through
slides sort of like the movie
theaters do with the question
and answer.
You know, this actor appeared
in seven shows before he
appeared on Lost
kind of thing.
The other one, what Fraser was
talking about, about being
able to reserve a location.
I think it ties into a bigger
issue that I was thinking
about the other day.
Which is, stuff slides through
my stream so fast.
And I go back looking for it,
and I often can't find it.
So I'll have a conversation
with somebody--
I noticed it during the run
up to the Kickstarter.
I'd have a conversation with
somebody, and we'd work out
the details, and then a week and
a half later, I'd go oh,
where's that?
And I wouldn't be able
to find it again.
And it was there.
Eventually I found it.
But It would be really nice to
be able to bookmark or to have
an internal way of bookmarking
threads in Google+.
So that I can have, not just
circles, but I can have a list
of threads that I'm trying
to keep an eye on.
Then that would solve Fraser's
problem, I think, that you'd
be able to put up a note and
say, coming up soon, in five
days, we're going to do
the Venus transit.
And then people would be
able to bookmark that.
And then when it comes out
again, they'd be able to keep
an eye on it.
I don't know if that would
totally solve Fraser's
problem, but that would solve
some other issues.
FRASER: We just need
to be able to--
if we're going to have an event
that's going to happen,
and we're going to
be broadcasting.
The next big chance is the
Curiosity Rover's going to be
landing on Mars in
August or July.
Anyway, we're going
to be doing live
coverage of that landing.
But the problem is we have to
do our publicity, get our
press release out, tell
everybody two weeks in
advance, a week in advance, so
that everyone can write their
articles, and they can
have a place to go.
And it would be great if that
place was on YouTube or on
Google+ that just says yep, they
type in the URL, boom,
they go there and
it's happening.
If they show up an hour early,
then they just see a screen
that says it's not here yet.
And if they show up an hour
later, then it's in progress.
CHAD: And you've configured your
channel to broadcast when
someone goes to your channel's
homepage if there's a live
event, that it automatically
streams.
Mike Downes has done a lot of
experimentation for the
documentation of that.
You could also set up
a landing page for
people to go to.
And as you're beginning that
Hangout and you're about to
broadcast it, embed that video
on that landing page, or like
an event page.
JENNY: That's another
great idea.
So these are all things
we're aware of.
And you've already mentioned
some work-arounds for some of
these cases, and there's
actually one that you guys
didn't mention a work-arou
d to, which is basically
bookmarking posts on important
discussions and stuff using
Google+ itself.
And there is a work-around for
this that I use pretty often.
I've create a circle, mine is
called Empty, it has no one in
it, but you could call
it Favorite Threads.
And what I do is when there's
a thread I know I need to go
back to, I will reshare that
post to that circle.
And then I go look at that
circle, and I can see all of
those very important posts.
CHARLES: Right, OK.
JENNY: And it's a little bit of
a wonky work-around but it
actually works pretty well.
CHARLES: Interesting.
CHIRAG: When I think about it,
that's really awesome.
JENNY: Yeah, it was an idea
that someone actually
mentioned during one
of these Hangouts.
I forgot who, though.
So I'm not taking
credit for that.
I didn't come up that.
That's an answer from
the community.
JASON: So would it be possible,
if you guys were to
be able to provide the
infrastructure, where we could
actually run apps or extensions
prior to a Hangout
going live?
JENNY: So pre-roll applications
are kind of an
interesting case, because
there's no one who will really
interact with it.
So it's not going to be able to
take advantage of all the
cool features that make
Hangout apps special.
It's just going to be a regular
HTML5 application.
But that's still pretty cool,
and you can actually do that
today using a little bit of a
work-around that was actually
mentioned is just doing
screen sharing.
So you take your application
that uses or pulls in data,
pulls in stock quotes or
relevant information or trivia
about the people who are about
to be on the Hangout.
And then you run that web
application in a regular
browser and screen share it,
and you'll actually get
probably about 90%
of the way there.
But that all being said,
pre-roll applications would be
something that would overlap a
lot with the kind of Hangout
view of an application itself.
So it is something we're aware
of, and it would be cool, but
I don't have much else
to say about it.
JASON: No, that's cool.
I mean, I was thinking that
would be kind of like a
logical thing to do just
for people out there.
And I mean, I know that's a fair
amount of work just for
something that niche
and that specific.
But maybe subcategorize and
say you can have a Hangout
app, or you can have a Hangout
extension, or you can have a
Hangout pre-roll service and
everything like that, just so
you can even further sandbox
it, just so it's fairly
limited and everything.
And if you're still running the
screenshare, then you hear
everybody else's audio feed
running underneath it, and if
you're the host you have to mute
everybody and everything.
But I totally get it.
I mean, functionally that
would totally work.
JENNY: Yep, we're definitely
aware of the larger problem of
being able to have Hangouts,
specifically Hangouts On Air,
that make it easy for people
to find the Hangouts On Air
that they're interested in, and
being able to get to them
when it's relevant.
And the work-around of having a
pre-roll, which we've used,
and the Android Developer
Relations Team also has put a
lot of work into their
pre-rolls, is one of the ways
that we've kind of added a 5-
or 10-minute buffer where
people have an opportunity to
reshare and queue up for the
broadcast before it begins.
But the larger problem of
being able to find the
Hangouts On Air that are
interesting to you is
something we're definitely
interested in.
JASON: Oh, cool, thank you.
JENNY: You're welcome,
thank you.
So we're actually getting pretty
close to out of time.
Do we have any questions from
the rest of the world we want
to tackle before we
start to wrap up?
CHIRAG: I think we've covered
most of the questions.
JENNY: Cool, that's great.
CHARLES: Jenny, I'm
totally stealing
your idea about resharing.
It's brilliant.
JENNY: Well, great.
Well, we stole it from the
Android Developer Relations
Team, so feel free to pass that
information along to everyone.
It works really well.
FRASER: Yeah, we've been using
that pre-roll technique, the
one that you did on this
Hangout, and it's fantastic.
It, again, sort of minimizes the
freakout in the first five
minutes when you're trying to
get all your preparation done
when you need to be public,
so that's fantastic.
JENNY: You also get a really
great audio track of the
people in the Hangout during
the pre-roll slide.
That's always a really
fun bonus feature.
A few of you join and there's
some audio there, whether it
be music or just people chatting
about the weather.
CHAD: I have a couple
of really short
questions, if I may.
JENNY: Of course.
CHAD: Are we making any progress
on having like a host
ID for an On Air in the API,
and trash collection, like
clearing image resources?
JENNY: So two questions
in there.
The first one is having a
specific Hangout user that is
the host of the Hangout, and
having that exposed via the
Hangout's API.
CHAD: Exactly.
JENNY: That would
be really cool.
The only place there's kind of
a concept of the host right
now is when a Hangout goes On
Air, because there's the
person broadcasting it.
In other Hangout situations,
the Hangout itself kind of
lives beyond the individuals
in it, and they can kind of
keep moving on.
So for that reason, the concept
of a host ID is
something that's a bigger
challenge where we're still
kind of working on figuring
that out.
CHAD: I like the creator
ID, in the context
of a regular Hangout.
JENNY: That would definitely
be a good place to start.
We don't have that yet.
CHAD: I'm aware.
JENNY: And moderation controls
in general, and especially
exposing stuff like that to the
API are something that's
on our radar, but nothing
to report right now.
And what was your
second question?
CHAD: Garbage collection.
If we have too many image
resources, that just stacks up
in the memory and ultimately
can crash.
So I'm wondering if we have
anything on the way to clear
those resources?
JENNY: So clearing the attached
image and audio
resources, it's gotten
a little bit better.
You may have noticed, especially
since it's gotten
much better than a
few months ago.
And we're working to keep
continually improving that.
But you're right, you
can still load up a
lot of image resources.
I think in the last bench
test they did it was--
for me it was a couple
thousand jpegs before
it wiped that out.
But there's a lot of cool cases
where you'll want to
load tons of image resources
over the life of the Hangout.
For example, if you want a
little video feed in the
corner or something.
We're working on it.
CHAD: OK.
JASON: One more quick one,
unless we're running out of
time, Jenny.
JENNY: Go ahead.
JASON: The facial tracking
feature is absolutely
phenomenal.
Especially some people in this
room are doing some brilliant
work with it.
But I ran into a situation last
night where I was writing
an HTML5 game, and then I had
built it out to say support
keyboard, support possibly
gamepad, support mouse
features and everything
like that.
But I was like you know, this
would be really cool, and I
want to extend it for Hangouts,
if I would be able
to have it support,
not necessarily my
face, but my hands.
So would it be possible to
extend the API to, in addition
to doing facial tracking, at
least the inside of my palms,
if not every one of my fingers
either independently or
collectively.
JENNY: That's a really
great question.
I have a little experience
with it.
Do you guys have?
SILVANO: You can find there's a
lot of, well not a lot, but
several open source Javascript
libraries that provide
tracking for hands
and everything.
I don't know how it will work,
so if you want to experiment
with it and let us know how it
works, we will be very happy.
Because the problem can be
you have the face, and
you have the hands.
And all the examples that I've
seen, usually they just show
the hands, and then they show
the point, but you can see
only the hands in the video.
And what I'm wondering is,
you are in a Hangout.
The scene is not that big, and
that's a lot of elements.
I'm not really sure how it will
work in the end, but it
will be cool.
ALLEN: That actually brings up
a question that we had on the
mailing list.
The biggest problem with doing
that, though, is that we have
no way to get the video image
that's currently being
displayed right now.
Is that correct, or is there a
way that I'm not aware of that
we can get a frame of what's
currently going on on the
video in order to do that
kind of analysis?
JENNY: You cannot [INAUDIBLE]
anything, that's correct.
You can't get the video stream
or the frames yet.
That's definitely something that
we know would unlock a
lot of potential for
features like this.
But it is not available yet.
Hang tight.
Specifically in regard to hand
tracking, I've done a little
bit of playing with these things
in the past, and I've
noticed that the hand tracking
algorithms are significantly
more computationally extensive
than facial
tracking, for some reason.
GERWIN: But you can just
draw a face on your
hands, and then it works.
CHAD: Or it's symbol
recognition, like on some
augmented reality setups, where
you can print a symbol
on a card and move the card
around the screen.
It replaces the symbol on the
card by just the pattern
recognition.
And that would be easier
than hand.
JASON: Well, also I'm thinking
because if you're monitoring,
and you're tracking your hands
also, and the system is
already monitoring the position
of your eyebrows,
each eye, and your lips and
everything, and then you've
got your hands moving around,
and your fingers in whatever
type of configuration.
Those are floating, and those
are actually going on top of
your face, so those might also
conflict with your facial
tracking anyway,
I would think.
But, yeah, I would also assume
that that would really slow
down your machine.
JENNY: It is a complicated
problem to solve.
Cool, okey-doke.
Well, unless there are any
other questions, we're
probably going to wrap
it up for the day.
Anything else from
the streams?
CHIRAG: I think that's
about it.
JENNY: Great, okey-doke.
Well, thanks so much for
joining us, everyone.
It's another great session
of the Office Hours.
Thanks for coming, especially
those of you who either fought
jet lag or rolled out of bed
really early in the morning to
come and join us on here.
We'll be seeing you later,
broadcasting from a different
location, currently undisclosed
but you'll find
out soon enough.
OK, bye everyone!
ALLEN: Bye.
CHARLES: Thanks.
CHAD: Thank you.